I'd love to go on this it looks so much
fun this kid is my new hero he's gonna
be an inventor of the future we dropped
in on Benjamin at his home in Denmark to
ask the engineering prodigy about his
electrified board I was used to ride my
long go to school and then like a really
bored of driving normally so I made run
electric it's a little bit hard to
describe what it's like to ride but it's
when you stand on it then just press the
front and just fly away and just get the
wind in you hit and just like whoa it's
just amazing so how does he make this
amazing longboard work to power the
whole thing he's using an electric drill
he connects the drill to the back of the
longboard and then puts the shaft of the
sprocket into the electric drill now
when he turns the drill on the power of
the drill is transferred through the
chain to the wheels
Benjamin is repurposing the brake handle
and cable from his bicycle as his
accelerator he's taking the cable from
the brakes and he's wounded around the
trigger of the drill when he squeezes
the brake cable it pulls the throttle
which switches on the drill and powers
the longboard a nice thing about the
drill is it gives Benjamin two speeds
there's two gears and the drill the
first one goes about 40 kilometres per
hour and the second one I think it's 80
I've not tried it yet I have to try it
someday wait 80 km/h that's 50 miles per
hour that's really fast it may be too
fast but who guess
this kids ingenuitive he's creative and
he already grasped these fundamentals of
science
he'll Benjamin